RUSSIAN-BACKED MERCENARIES ARE
CLAIMING VICTORY OVER THE
ENTIRE INDUSTRIAL TOWN OF
SOLEDAR.
UKRAINE'S MILITARY ADMITS
FIERCE BATTLES ARE GOING ON
THERE.
BUT SAYS THAT ITS FORCES HAVE
THINGS UNDER CONTROL.
THE BATTLE FOR SOLEDAD'S
BLOODY.
A UKRAINIAN SOLDIER TELLS CNN
THAT THE DEATH TOLL IS NOW SO
HIGH THAT THEY'VE STOPPED
COUNTING THE DEAD.
SOLEDAD IS LOCATED IN THE
DONETSK REGION.
NOT FAR FROM THE CITY OF
BUCKINGHAM.
TO THE BIGGEST SALT MINE IN
EUROPE.
AND A VAST NETWORK OF
UNDERGROUND TUNNELS.
WHICH RUSSIAN FORCES ARE LIKELY
TO EXPLOIT.
MORE NOW ON THE FIGHTING IN
SOLIDARITY FROM CNN'S SCOTT
MCLAIN.
REPORTING FROM KYIV.
>> SMOKE BILLOWS OVER THE SALT
MINES IN SOLEDAR.
EASTERN UKRAINE.
THIS SMALL TOWN NOW THE SCENE
OF SOME OF THE FIERCEST
FIGHTING IN THE 11TH MONTH WAR.
VIDEO FILMED BY A SOLDIER ON
THE FRONTLINE SHOWS THE HOUSE
TO HOUSE STYLE FIGHTING.
TROOPS ARE NOW LOCKED INTO.
THE TANK IS WORKING, DID YOU
HEAR?
UKRAINIAN FIGHTER SAYS.
THE STREETS LITTERED WITH
DEBRIS.
AS FIGHTERS BATTLE FOR CONTROL
OF THE STRATEGIC TOWN.
THIS PART OF THE WAR'S
FRONTLINE IS DOMINATED BY THE
PRIVATE MILITARY GROUPS.
WAGNER HEAD YEVGENY PRIGOZHIN
PRAISING THE BRAVERY OF THE
UKRAINIAN FORCES HE IS TRYING
TO DEFEAT.
IT MEETING ON SUNDAY THAT HIS
MEN WERE EXCLUSIVELY WORKING TO
CAPTURE THE TOWN IN THE MINES
UNDERNEATH SOLEDAD FROM
BUCKINGHAM.
THE TOWN WALLS ARE ALMOST
ENTIRELY DEMOLISHED.
ACCORDING TO UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS.
SOLEDAR, THOSE SMALL IN SIZE,
IS STRATEGICALLY IMPORTANT TO
THE ULTIMATE CAPTURE MCNUTT.
A WAY OF SURROUNDING THE CITY
FROM THE NORTH AND DISRUPTING
UKRAINE COMMUNICATION LINES.
>> THE BATTLE FOR THE DONBAS
CONTINUES.
ALTHOUGH THE OCCUPIERS HAVE NO
CONCENTRATED THEIR EFFORTS ON
FLORIDA, THE RESULT OF THIS
DIFFICULT AND PROLONG THE
BATTLE WILL BE THE LIBERATION
OF OUR ENTIRE DONBAS.
>> UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY MONDAY
ACKNOWLEDGED THE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT SITUATION IN SOLEDAD.
RUSSIA MEANWHILE IS STILL
REELING OVER THE DEVASTATING
UKRAINIAN STRIKE ON TROOPS
HOUSED IN KYIV GOT ON NEW
YEAR'S DAY.
MOSCOW SAYING THAT 89
SERVICEMAN WAS KILLED.
UKRAINE SAYS THERE WERE
HUNDREDS.
RUSSIA SAYS IT WILL NOT PUBLISH
THEIR NAMES.
CLAIMING IT WILL HELP FOREIGN
INTERNET ACTIVITIES AGAINST
THEM.
AS FIGHTING RAGES ON, ALL EYES
ARE ON WHEN AND IF IT MAY FALL.
SCOTT MCLAIN, CNN, KYIV.
>> THE PENTAGON CONFIRMS THAT
IT WILL BEGIN TRAINING
UKRAINIAN TROOPS ON THE MISSILE
SYSTEM IN THE U.S. AS SOON AS
NEXT WEEK.
BETWEEN 90 AND 100 SOLDIERS
WILL VISIT FORT SILL IN
OKLAHOMA FOR THE PROGRAM.
WHICH IS EXPECTED TO TAKE
SEVERAL MONTHS.
CNN'S CLARE SEBASTIAN IS
FOLLOWING THE LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS FOR US AND JOINS
US LIVE FROM LONDON.
WANTING TO CLARE.
WHAT MORE ARE YOU LEARNING
ABOUT THESE UKRAINIAN TROOPS
SAID TO BEGIN TRAINING ON THE
PATRIOT MISSILE SYSTEM HERE IN
THE U.S..
NEXT WEEK.
>> WAS, BY A SIGNIFICANT STEP
FOR UKRAINIAN FORCES TO BE
HEADING TO THE U.S. FOR
TRAINING.
THE U.S. HAS FOUR CONTACTS BEEN
TRAINING FORCES IN EUROPE.
PARTICULARLY IN GERMANY.
PLANNING TO STEP UP THE
PROGRAM.
BUT THIS WOULD BE 9200
UKRAINIAN TROOPS WHO, AS SOON
AS NEXT WEEK WILL BE HEADING TO
FORT SILL IN OKLAHOMA.
THE TRAINING FACILITY THAT THE
U.S. USES TO TRAIN ITS OWN
SOLDIERS.
ON THAT PATRIOT BATTERY.
THEY ARE PLANNING TO EXPEDITE
THE USUAL TIMELINE FOR THIS
TRAINING.
TYPICALLY IT CAN TAKE UP TO A
YEAR TO TRAIN SOLDIERS TO USE
THE PATRIOT MISSILE DEFENSE
SYSTEM.
BUT THEY PLAN TO GET IT DONE IN
SEVERAL MONTHS.
CLEARLY THEY WANT TO EXPEDITE
TO MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT THE TROOPS SPEND AWAY FROM
THE BATTLEFIELD.
AND TO GET THE PATRIOT BATTERY
TO WHERE IT IS NEEDED THE MOST.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY STEPPING UP
HIS CALL FOR WESTERN AID IN HIS
NIGHTLY ADDRESS TUESDAY.
SAYING THAT THIS IS NOT EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT WITH RUSSIA
POTENTIALLY PLANNING A ANOTHER
ESCALATION.
I THINK SEVERAL MONTHS IS
PERHAPS TOO LONG FOR THE
PATRIOT MISSILE TO PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
BUT CLEARLY, STILL A VERY
PRIZED ADDITION TO THE WESTERN
MILITARY AID PACKAGE UKRAINE IS
SEEN.
>> ALL RIGHT, OUR THANKS TO
CLARE SEBASTIAN JOINING US LIVE
FROM LONDON.